hi schön dass ihr eingeschaltet habt
heute zu ZDF heute live heute mal ein
bisschen früher denn es gab eine
Erklärung der Bundesministerin der
Verteidigung von Christian Lambrecht die
in eben dieser Erklärung den
Bundeskanzler um Entlassung aus dem Amt
bittet das hat sich ja in den letzten
Wochen Monaten schon so ein bisschen
hochgeschaukelt seit Freitag wird im
politischen Berlin darüber gesprochen ob
dieser Rücktritt denn jetzt kommt und
jetzt haben wir hier die Erklärung
vorliegen und wir wollen heute hier
darüber sprechen was diese Erklärung
bedeutet wer vielleicht in Frage kommt
als Nachfolger oder Nachfolgerin aber
auch was aktuell die Herausforderungen
bei der Führung der Bundeswehr sind im
Jahr
2023 und dazu möchten wir heute sprechen
zum einen mit meinem Kollegen dem
hauptstadtkurs von Enten Thomas Reich
hat und dann mit dem ehemaligen
Nato-General Egon Rams und darüber
sprechen möchten wir natürlich wie immer
auch mit euch das heißt wenn ihr Fragen
oder Kommentare oder Anmerkungen zum
Thema habt schreibt die hier einfach in
den Youtube Chat oder schreibt uns eine
Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de ja und ich begrüße
jetzt mein Kollegen aus der Hauptstadt
Berlin den hauptstadtkorrespondenten
Thomas Reichert der mir hier
zugeschaltet ist hallo Thomas hallo
Viktoria ja Thomas wie überrascht warst
du denn heute noch von dieser Erklärung
von Frau Lamprecht also heute war ich
gar nicht mehr überrascht das hatte sich
ja am Freitagabend angekündigt einige
Medien Bild Süddeutsche und Spiegel
hatten da am Freitagabend schon darüber
berichtet wir haben am Freitagabend viel
umher telefoniert haben dazu keinen
Dementi vernommen und insofern war es im
Grunde übers Wochenende schon klar dass
Lamprecht zurücktreten wird die Frage
nur war nur wann sie das machen würde
wahrscheinlich heute davon sind wir
ausgegangen also der Rücktritt kann
nicht überraschend
dann jetzt dass er heute kam aber es hat
sich schon lange angekündigt in gewisser
Weise ich bin ehrlich gesagt davon
ausgegangen dass je mehr
Rücktrittsforderung es gibt desto eher
wird Kanzler Olaf Scholz sein Lambrecht
festhalten insofern war ich am Freitag
überrascht aber heute nicht mehr
du hast gerade schon gesagt dieser
Rücktritt hat sich irgendwo auch
angedeutet es gab ja in den letzten
Monaten eigentlich in dem kompletten
Jahr knapp ja diese Amtszeit von
Christian Lamprecht immer wieder
verschiedene Skandale Peinlichkeiten was
waren denn da so Punkte die für dich
besonders herausgestochen haben kannst
du uns vielleicht mal so einen kurzen
chronischen Abriss davon geben was Frau
Lambrecht im Amt vielleicht getan hat
weswegen diese Rücktrittsforderung
überhaupt aufgekommen sind
naja es ging ja im Grunde schon los kurz
nach ihrem Amtszeit tritt also kurz
nachdem die Ampel mit ihrer Arbeit
begonnen hat da gibt es das war in im
Dezember der Ampel Start und kurz vor
Weihnachten geht es den traditionellen
Besuch der Verteidigungsministerin bei
Auslandsmissionen der der Bundeswehr
Lamprecht hat ein bereits vereinten
Termin der abgesagt ist lieber kurz für
einen Tag eine Litauen und dann in den
Skiurlaub nach Ischgl das hat die Truppe
sehr verwundert und war erstmal schon
mal kein guter Auftakt dann gibt es gab
es den im Mai ein Helikopterflug mit
ihrem Sohn nach Norddeutschland gleich
im Anschluss sind die beiden dann
weitergefahren nach Sylt das hat erstens
Fragen darüber aufgebracht ob es
rechtens war wie da die Flugbereitschaft
der Bundeswehr genutzt wurde und es gab
Diskussionen um ein Foto das des Sohnes
dass er dann auf Social Media gepostet
hat so ging das weiter mit ganz
verschiedenen Sachen im Grunde muss man
sagen das waren letztlich mini-affären
ich glaube dass sie ihre Wucht und ihre
ihre zerstörerische Kraft was sozusagen
die die Reputation von Lamprecht im Amt
dann geht nur fahren dadurch entwickelt
haben das Land bricht selbst umgekehrt
nicht wirklich Neugier und Leidenschaft
für dieses Amt entwickelt hat ich habe
sie als
verteidigungspolitischer korrespondenter
die letzten Monate über verfolgt auch
auf Reisen zur zu Truppe und hatte immer
den Eindruck dass sie in diesen Amt nie
wirklich angekommen ist dass sie auch
nach Monaten zum Beispiel nicht wirklich
sprechfähig ist dass sie zum Beispiel
bei Schalke sprechen sich aus meiner
Sicht in meiner Wahrnehmung oft dann
vorformulierten Stanzen festgehalten hat
das heißt diese Kombination einerseits
die Miniaturen andererseits ein
Ministerin die schwach ist in ihrem Amt
und das all das in einer Situation mit
dem Krieg in der Ukraine sozusagen der
größten sicherheitspolitischen
Herausforderung für Deutschland seit dem
Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs das alles
hat im Grunde das wir gesagt dass seit
Wochen und Monaten immer wieder
rücktrittsförderung kam und jetzt ist es
eben passiert
du hast gerade auch schon gesagt dass du
eigentlich erwartet hast die größer
diese Rücktrittsforderung werden desto
eher hält Kanzler Scholz noch zu seiner
Verteidigungsministerin jetzt hat sie
uns hat sie ja heute den Kanzler um
Entlassung aus dem Amt gebeten meine
erste Frage dazu ist das jetzt formell
noch ein Unterschied zu einem Rücktritt
also so ein bitten um Entlassung und
meine zweite Frage was bedeutet das denn
jetzt für Kanzler Olaf Scholz glaubst du
er wird sich dazu heute noch äußern
also ein entlastungsgesuch ist quasi der
Rücktritt da gibt es da gibt es keinen
Unterschied es gibt keinen Zweifel daran
dass
das Scholz diesen Wunsch entsprechend
wird den Vernehmen nach haben die beiden
schon seit längerem über einen möglichen
Rücktritt von landbrech gesprochen und
ich gehe fest davon aus dass diese
Schreiben dieses ähm die Suche um
Entlassung bereits das mit mit Holz und
dem Kanzleramt natürlich abgesprochen
ist du stolz ist heute ähm bis zum
Nachmittag nicht in Berlin es sind in
Baden-Württemberg in Ulm besuchte heute
erstmal eine Brauerei und danach einen
eine Rüstungskonzern für den frühen
Nachmittag ist da sowieso ein Statement
vorgesehen ich kann mir schlecht
allerdings nicht vorstellen dass sie
sich zu der Sache nicht äußern wird was
er aber offenbar auch nicht machen wird
ist schon gleich ein Nachfolger oder
deine Nachfolgerin zu benennen da müssen
wir offenbar noch warten das Prekäre
verscholz ist ja letztlich dass er an
Lambrecht so lange festgehalten hat
einerseits weil es sozusagen so eine
solche trotzigkeit ist gerade wenn die
Opposition wenn märz und Dobrind das
besonders laut fand dass er dann gerade
deshalb an seiner Ministerin festert und
andererseits glaube ich weiß für ihn
auch in gewisser Weise komoot eine
schwache Ministerin im
Verteidigungsministerium zu haben
wesentliche Teile der
Verteidigungspolitik insbesondere was
Unterstützung für die Ukraine angeht
oder den Umbau der Bundeswehrzeiten der
Zeitenwende kam aus dem Kanzleramt des
Burg Verteidigungsministerium war in den
letzten Monaten quasi eine nachgeordnete
Behörde des Bundeskanzleramtes und
wesentlich Entscheidungen würden dort
getroffen es wird jetzt spannend zu sein
zu sehen wie stark der oder die
Nachfolgerin für Christine Lamprecht
sein wird ob das sich sozusagen die
Gewichte dann wieder Richtung
Bendlerblock also Richtung
Verteidigungsministerium verlagern
werden
ja Thomas und während wir hier darüber
sprechen kam gerade die Meldung rein von
Reuters das Kanzler Scholz diese
Erklärung oder diese diese Bitte um
Entlassung akzeptiert hat also hier
haben sie quasi live gerade die
Ereignisse noch ein bisschen überholt
auf meine Frage aber du hast schon den
Punkt angesprochen Nachfolger
Nachfolgerin und was das auch vielleicht
für die Verschiebung von Macht zwischen
Kanzleramt und Verteidigungsministerium
bedeuten kann jetzt haben wir in den
letzten Tagen schon ganz viel über
mögliche Personalien gehört kannst du
uns doch noch mal kurz einen Überblick
geben wer da gerade im Rennen ist bzw im
Gespräch und wie du die Chancen
einschätzt also wichtig zu wissen ist
glaube ich das erstmal dass die
Entscheidung wer Verteidigungsminister
oder Ministerin wird eine Entscheidung
der SPD ist in der Ampel ist es so
vereinbart dass die drei
Koalitionspartner sozusagen ihre
Ministerien besetzen das heißt erster
Punkt
Nachfolger Nachfolgerin von Lamprecht
wird auf jeden Fall ein SPD Lehrerin
werden das macht es gleichzeitig schon
mal schwer weil es in der SPD keine so
nicht so viele basierte
Verteidigungspolitiker gibt bei der
Sozialpolitik ist das anders aber
Verteidigungspolitik da ist es eher
übersichtlich die nahmen die jetzt
gehandelt werden sind einerseits sind
die Möller Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin im
Verteidigungsministerium seit langem im
Verteidigungsausschuss im Bundestag aber
eben noch relativ jung
unerfahren und möglicherweise noch nicht
mit der nötigen politischen Schwerkraft
für das schwierigste kabinettsamt muss
man wirklich sagen dann ist der Eva Högl
ebenfalls SPD klar
die werbeauftragte sich sozusagen die
Anwältin der der Soldaten im Bundestag
auch sie ist sozusagen relativ frisch in
dieses Amt gekommen hat sich aber in der
kurzen Zeit anders als das Land bricht
er sehr gut eingearbeitet hat einen sehr
guten Ruf bei der Truppe aber auch da
aber die sagen ist es eher
unwahrscheinlich dass sie Nachfolgerin
wird weitere Namen sind Wolfgang Schmidt
Kanz
Finanzminister und sozusagen die rechte
Hand von Olaf Scholz könnte man sich da
ganz gut vorstellen allerdings hat
Schmidt Scholz sozusagen über Jahrzehnte
begleitet es ist kaum vorstellbar dass
er jetzt sozusagen von seiner Seite
weichen wird oder jedenfalls wer ist
eine dicke Überraschung als auch jemand
der bisher sehr die Öffentlichkeit
gemieden hat und die müsste er natürlich
suchen wenn er als Verteidigungsminister
antreten würde Hubertus Heil wird auch
genannt der Sozialminister
der Arbeits- und Sozialminister der da
auch gehandelt wird
man wird es sehen ich habe den Eindruck
Hubertus Heilbad sein Amt im Moment sehr
gern aber im Zweifel musste sich da in
die Pflicht nehmen lassen ich weiß es
schlicht noch nicht und ich habe den
Eindruck auch das ganze politische
Berlin schaut da sehr gespannt darauf
wie gesagt Entscheidung soll angeblich
heute noch nicht fallen sondern mit
Blick möglicherweise dann aufs am
Mittwoch erst
ja das sind auf jeden Fall einige Namen
einige bekannte Namen die da auch im
Rennen sind und da haben wir eine Frage
aus der Community an Dich Thomas die
sich da so ein bisschen anschließen
nämlich Sven Odendahl fragt auf Facebook
was bedeutet der Rücktritt und die neue
Einarbeitung eines neuen Ministers oder
einer neuen Ministerin für die
Zuverlässigkeit und Leistungsfähigkeit
der deutschen Regierung gegenüber der
NATO und der Ukraine weil wir haben das
hat der ist gerade schon angeklungen das
sind einige Namen die jetzt schon
bedeutenden Ämtern sind da wurde ja dann
auch noch entstehen
da würde in jedem Fall ein Loch
entstehen und es ist eine sehr richtige
und zutreffende Frage weil natürlich in
dieser Situation eine ganze Reihe von
Termin allein in dieser Woche anstehen
wo sehr sehr wichtige Entscheidungen
anstehen die wichtigste vielleicht am
Freitag trifft sich die sogenannte
Rammstein Kontaktgruppe in Rammstein
Unterführung des amerikanischen
Verteidigungsministers und da wird es um
die Frage gehen wie kann die Ukraine mit
Blick auf eine drohende
Frühjahrsoffensive Russlands unterstützt
werden da geht es um Kampfpanzer und es
geht um die Frage ist Deutschland bereit
die Zustimmung zu geben dass andere
Länder Leopard 2 Panzer an die Ukraine
liefern wird es möglicherweise selbst
auch Kampfpanzer liefern stolz dass ich
da bisher nicht geäußert hat darauf ähm
betont dass er das alles mit Bedacht und
in Abstimmung mit anderen machen würden
aber die anderen schreiten und voran das
heißt eine Entscheidung steht der an
und die müsste dann in jedem Fall der
Nachfolge wie Nachfolgerin von
landbrecht am Freitag in Ramstein
vertreten also das ist sozusagen ein
fliegender Wechsel und das ist
wahrscheinlich noch eine Untertreibung
die wir da gerade sehen
ja du sprichst es gerade schon an
fliegender Wechsel wir haben auf Youtube
auch eine Frage von Wiesel Design der
fragt wenn das noch nicht besprochen
worden ist wie lange wird denn die
übergabezeit dauern wenn ein neuer
verteidigungs-
Thomas ich sehe dich gar nicht mehr wir
sehen hier gerade ich komme gerade
wieder ins Bild ah aber ich höre ihn
wunderbar wir haben eine automatische
Kamera hier in Berlin und die hat hatte
offenbar die Nase voll von mir und hat
sich weggedreht jetzt bin ich wieder da
bist du wieder da da freuen wir uns alle
es gibt nämlich einige Fragen an dich
aus der Community wenn das noch nicht
besprochen worden ist du hast es gerade
schon angesprochen relativ knappe
übergabezeit wie lange wird denn so eine
Übergabe Zeit dauern wenn jetzt ein
neuer Minister fest steht ist das dann
unverzüglich also ist das eine Sache von
einem Tag oder wie läuft sowas ab das
ist in der Sache eine Sache von einem
Tag also gehen wir mal von dem Mittwoch
aus
da wird dann
der oder die neue Ministerin verkündet
wird dann unmittelbar in Bendlerblock
das heißt das Gebäude des
Verteidigungsministeriums hier in Berlin
auftreten wird vermutlich da wird
vermutlich eine Amtsübergabe von
landbrecht zu ihm oder ihr geben und
dann geht es los
man darf ja auch nicht vergessen das
Verteidigungsministerium hat eine Menge
Mitarbeiter es gibt sozusagen ein
bürokratischen Staat es gibt ein
militärischen Stab also
er stützt wäre oder sie stützt sich das
schon auf viele Leute mit mit sehr viel
Ahnung aber klar es ist sozusagen wie
gesagt ein fliegender Wechsel in einer
Situation wo es wirklich auf jeden
Schritt und jeden Tritt ankommt
ja danke Thomas bis hierhin ich bin mir
sicher du wirst diesen fliegenden
Wechsel begleiten wir natürlich auch
vielen dank dir für die Antworten auf
die Fragen unserer Community
und wir schalten jetzt einmal rüber zum
ehemaligen Nato-General Egon Rams denn
es ist sicher auch interessant über
Personalien zu sprechen dann aber auch
mal zu gucken was muss denn der neue
Verteidigungsminister oder die neue
Verteidigungsministerin jetzt inhaltlich
ganz konkret angeben hallo Herr Rams
schön dass Sie bei uns sind
schönen guten Tag Frau Reichelt ja wir
haben es gerade schon so ein bisschen
gehört da stehen ja diese Woche noch
einige wichtige Termine für den neuen
Verteidigungsminister oder die
neuverteidigungsministerin an können Sie
uns mal kurz zusammenfassen was genau
wird bei diesem Termin besprochen und
was müsste dort dann die Neubesetzung
ganz konkret leisten was würde von ihr
oder ihm erwartet werden
also wenn sie mir erlauben möchte ich
noch mal ein bisschen in die Personal
Diskussion ihres Korrespondenten
Eingreifen das Interessante ist ja das
hat er selber auch schon betont dass
alle die er namlich genannt hat irgendwo
ein anderer Stelle ein Loch reißen
welches dann auch wieder gestopft werden
muss das heißt man muss dann nicht nur
danach gucken wer ist der geeignete
Verteidigungsminister oder die geeignete
verteilungsministerin sondern muss man
beispielsweise beim Schmidt auch die
Frage stellen wer ist der gehackte
Kanzleramtsminister z.B oder eine Frau
Hügel nimmt wer ist denn dann der
Nachfolger als werbeauftragter
Nachfolger danach folge darin ich hätte
da noch einen positiven oder gut
geeigneten Kandidaten der nach meiner
Auffassung auch eine sehr hohe kalt
stattfähigkeit mitbringen für das
Verteidigungsministerium das ist der
ehemalige werbeauftragter Hans Peter
Bartels
der hat im Augenblick keine Ämter in
dieser Richtung er war mehrere Jahre
Vorsitzender des verteilungsausschusses
er war fünf Jahre lang werbeauftragter
von daher bringt ja in meinen Augen
Voraussetzungen mit für die
kaltstartfähigkeit und für das Amt als
Ganzes auch was eine Kompetenz angeht
die kaum ein anderer Kandidat hätte aber
ist bisher nicht in der Diskussion warum
vermag ich nicht zu sagen das sind zieht
sich meinem Zugriff einfach aufgrund der
Tatsache dass ich da in die Innereien
oder in die Talas der
sozialdemokratische Partei Deutschland
nicht zurück zu ihrer Frage Stichwort
kalt stattfähigkeit der neue Minister
oder die neue Ministerin muss im Prinzip
sofort von 0 auf 100 gebracht werden was
sicherlich nicht einfach ist wegen der
Komplexität der Aufgaben und ich möchte
insbesondere die Rammstein Konferenz
oder Rammstein Kontaktgruppe erwähnen
die dann in dieser Woche bereits
entsprechende Entscheidung oder
entsprechende Verhandlung verlangt dass
es einen eine hohe Anforderung an einen
neuen Minister nach einer neuen
Ministerin in diesem Kreis im Prinzip
sagt man von Anfang an als
diskussionsfähig mit zu arbeiten und man
darf auch nicht vergessen dass
Deutschland im Rahmen der NATO aber auch
im Rahmen der Europäischen Union ja ein
Schwergewicht ist und von daher sage ich
mal eine entsprechende Rolle in dieser
Art und Weise wahrgenommen werden muss
die anderen Dinge es ist fertiggestellt
oder mehr oder weniger fertiggestellt
der Zustandsbericht der Bundeswehr dazu
gibt es einen Entwurf der ist bisher
nicht öffentlich muss noch abgestimmt
werden aber in dieser Phase einen
Rücktritt zu haben und einen neuen
Minister zu improvisieren wir dann
möglicherweise sagt ich möchte diesen
Zustandsbericht der Bundeswehr noch mal
überprüfen oder kontrollieren oder das
gefällt mir nicht oder das muss
vielleicht anders gemacht werden ist
auch jedenfalls ein Risiko weil damit
auch mit Blick auf die Weiterentwicklung
der Bundeswehr hinsichtlich
möglicherweise Strukturreform und andere
Dinge mehr erneut Zeit verloren gehen
von daher auch eine wichtige Aufgabe die
entsprechend angegangen werden muss und
die auch schnell
Fortschritte erzielen muss einfach um
den Zustand der Bundeswehr in der
jetzigen Zeit zu beenden und auf die
Zukunft ausgerichtet weiter vorzusetzen
dazu kommt die Tatsache dass die
Bundeswehr ja bei der Ausgabe des 100
Milliarden sondervermö
auch erst für das Jahr 2023 einen Anfang
gemacht hat und die anderen
beschaffungsentscheidung für diese
Sondervermögen anstehen und auch
entsprechend getroffen werden müssen
dazu erlaube ich mir eine Anmerkung das
was bisher entschieden worden ist sind
im Prinzip Auflösungen oder im
Wesentlichen kauflösungen die über die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
abgewickelt und gelöst werden das kann
kein Dauerzustand sein sondern es muss
auch darauf Auslaufen dass die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie die europäische
Rüstungsindustrie entsprechende Aufträge
bekommt damit sie ja leistungsfähig
bleibt und wie wir auch vielleicht nicht
ganz komplett abhängig werden von der
amerikanischen Seite auch das spielt
eine große politische Rolle wir haben
die Diskussion über die Ukraine und die
Kampfpanzer Lieferung für mich steht
fest dass der neue Verteidigungsminister
in diesem Themenbereich ebenfalls sehr
intensiv einsteigen muss zwangsläufig
einsteigen muss weil jeder Tag der für
die Unterstützung der Ukraine verloren
geht letztend von der Ukraine
Menschenleben kostet und das ist auch
eine wichtige Rolle das war jetzt nun
mal vier Punkte angerissen die eine
Bedeutung haben dazu kommt die neue
Haushaltsaufstellung und ähnliche Dinge
mir auch das Spiel eine Rolle vielleicht
können wir auf das Thema Haushalt für
das verteilungsministerium zum späteren
Zeitpunkt noch mal zurückkommen
ja also wir merken das ist ein ganz
großer bunter Blumenstrauß an Aufgaben
den die oder der Nachfolger erwartet ich
gucke gerade mal so ein bisschen in die
Kommentare aus der Community und es gibt
ein Thema was die Menschen die uns
gerade zuschauen auf jeden Fall bewegt
und dazu lese ich mal einen Kommentar zu
vor von
Jörg Sautner auf Facebook der sagt es
wäre jetzt allerbeste Zeit endlich ein
kompetenten Nachfolger zu nennen was
spricht eigentlich gern gegen einen
erfahrenen und altgedienten General der
die Bundeswehr und deren Bedürfnisse
sehr kennt und er ist damit nicht der
einzige auch Mike Triebe auf Youtube
fragt oder sagt als Statement ein
Nachfolger sollte ein General ade sein
der weiß was die Truppe braucht herrns
warum kann ein General nicht
Verteidigungsministerin werden oder was
sagen sie dazu
theoretisch könnte er schon also das ist
aber jetzt gleich mal blanke Theorie
der verteilungsminister muss ja weder in
einer Partei sein noch muss der
Bundestag sein wobei beides natürlich
von Vorteil wäre weil er dann als
Minister in der jeweiligen Fraktion
verankert wäre dass der eine Punkt dabei
und der zweite Punkt ist der dass er
dann auch im parlamentarischen Raum
entsprechendes Netzwerk hat und die
Partei stützt ihn dabei von daher
parteilos und nach der Pensionierung
verteilungsminister zu werden ist dann
auch schon wieder eine besondere Aufgabe
weil das Umfeld und das Netzwerk fehlt
dass der eine Punkt aber ich glaube der
wichtigere Punkt ist der das ist in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland im Prinzip
sollte Entstehung der Bundeswehr in den
50er Jahren ja ich sag mal eine
Tradition geworden ist auf diesem Stuhl
nicht unbedingt die Fachleute aus dem
militärischen Bereich
rauszuziehen und dort drauf zu setzen
dieses ist eine politische Aufgabe von
daher ist der Ansatz ein Politiker dafür
zu nehmen schon wichtiger Ansatz der
möchte ich aber jetzt noch einen Satz
hinzufügen wir haben dieses
Verteidigungsministerium mit den
verschiedenen Abteilungsleitern und den
Staatssekretären das ist im Prinzip ein
komplettes Organ sag ich mal welches
notwendig ist oder auch in der Lage ist
den Minister oder die Ministerin
entsprechend zu beraten und hier damit
die fachliche Kompetenz zu vermitteln
die notwendig ist um dieses Amt
auszuüben und das ist viele
Verteidigungsminister und
verteidigungsministerinnen vor Frau
Lamprecht eigentlich recht gut gelungen
das war mal bei dem ein oder anderen
besser oder bei dem ein oder anderen
schlechter und wir fallen eigentlich gar
nicht mal so spontan zwei
Verteidigungsministerin die diese
Aufgabe in diese Richtung sehr gut mit
der entsprechenden Beratung auch sehr
genau wahrgenommen haben der eine
beispielsweise ist Volker Rügen in den
90er Jahren jetzt zu Anfang seines Amtes
durchaus Schwierigkeiten mit den
generalien hatte sich aber dann
hinterher auf die Generale verlassen
konnten konnte in einem sehr loyal
Arbeitsverhältnis und der zweite der mir
einfängt Anfang der 2000er Jahre ist
Peter Strupp gewesen ja aus
Verteidigungsminister bei der Truppe
sehr beliebt war der die entsprechende
Entscheidung gefällt hat und der mit dem
Beraterteam der generale und
Abteilungsleiter auch ausgesprochen gut
zurecht gekommen ist von daher das geht
es muss also nicht unbedingt ein General
sein und die Möglichkeit dort einen
ehemaligen General zu leben halte ich
für ausgesprochen
ja wir haben ja einmal die Frage also
das der Vorerfahrung des Nachfolgers der
Nachfolgerin hier haben wir noch eine
Frage zum Geschlecht des Nachfolgers
oder der Nachfolgerin von eine CS über
Facebook die sagt hoffentlich lernt man
jetzt aus den letzten drei weiblichen
Fehlbesetzung und nimmt endlich einen
erfahrenen Mann vor dem die Soldaten
auch Achtung haben können Sie als
Experte ist das tatsächlich ein Faktor
den man mit bedenken muss wir wissen ja
Olaf Scholz wir sein Kabinett
paritätisch besetzen das heißt
eigentlich muss eine Frau Folgen wie
schätzen sie denn diese
Geschlechterfrage ein im
Verteidigungsministerium also wenn
Menschen für bestimmte Aufgaben
ausgesucht werden dann spricht man
eigentlich sehr gerne und auch sehr
zweckmäßig über das Thema Eignung
Leistung und Bewegung
und ich bin der Auffassung dass auch
nach den Erfahrungen jetzt und ich
betone das jetzt im Augenblick
man möglicherweise auf diesen
Geschlechter Ausgleich innerhalb des
Kabinetts zugunsten aller entsprechenden
Kompetenz verzichten sollte das ist auch
eine der Gründe warum ich in meinem
Frühling Ausführung Hans-peter Bartels
erwähnt habe wissend dass er keine Frau
ist aber dass er in der Lage ist von
seiner Kompetenzen von seinem Gewicht
her diese Aufgabe
ja hier haben wir noch eine Frage die so
ein bisschen an ihre bisherige Erfahrung
als General appelliert nämlich vom Chris
what der schreibt Herr Rams als
ehemaliger General wie waren ihre
Erfahrung mit den Ministern mit denen
sie gearbeitet haben was wäre die
primäre Eigenschaft die man mitbringen
sollte wenn man das so sagen kann
ich würde zwei primäre Eigenschaften
nennen erstens die Erfahrung die ich mit
Ministern gehabt habe waren
unterschiedlich ich war das erste Mal im
Verteidigungsministerium da war Manfred
Manfred Wörner verteilungsminister ich
habe Herrn rühr erlebt ich habe Herrn
Scharping erlebt ich habe einen Druck
erlebt ich habe einen Jungen erlebt von
daher da lässt sich kein einheitliches
Urteil bilden das ist schon sehr
unterschiedlich die beiden Eigenschaften
die ich betonen würde ist einmal die
Eigenschaft er muss die Möglichkeit
haben die Fähigkeit haben zuzuhören das
gilt sowohl in der großen
abteilungsleiterkonferenz die im
Ministerium regelmäßig stattfinden
sollte als Verfahren regelmäßig
stattfinden sollte das geht aber in
gleicher Art und Weise wenn er bei der
Truppe ist und dienstauf sich bei der
Truppe macht den Soldaten den
Kommandeuren aber auch dem einfachen
Soldaten zuhören zu können und die
Botschaften die in diese Menschen
übermitteln entsprechend aufzunehmen und
dann auch zu verarbeiten und sie
hinterher Ministerien dann weiter
umzusetzen der zweite Punkt der nach
meiner Auffassung wichtig ist dass nach
einem solchen Beratungsprozess und dem
Zuhören dann eher auch eine
entsprechende Entscheidungsfreude an den
Tag legt denn nicht die schlimmer für
Soldaten das gilt beispielsweise auch
jetzt bei den Entscheidungen für Ukraine
Krieg und dergleichen mehr als wenn
Entscheidungen auf die lange Bank
geschoben werden und nicht gefällt
werden dabei mag es sein dass es
passieren kann dass eine Entscheidung
weil in geringen Umfang nicht die 100%
richtige Entscheidung ist das kann man
nachbessern aber wichtig ist das eine
Entscheidung getroffen wird an der sich
dann die Soldaten das Ministerium sagt
man der ganze Apparat entsprechend
orientieren kann
ja also
Entscheidungsfreude das kann man auf
jeden Fall mal mitnehmen für seine
persönlichen politischen Analysen des
Nachfolgers der Nachfolgerin wir haben
hier einmal eine Nachricht noch oder ein
Ton von Christiane Hoffmann sie ist
Regierungssprecherin und hat sich eben
zum Rücktritt der Bundesministerin
geäußert schauen wir mal rein
was die nach Besetzung von Frau
Lambrecht angeht habe ich ja gesagt dass
das zeitnah entschieden werden wird
zeitnah ist auf keinen Fall drei Monate
aber es aus gutem Grund wird es heute
aller Voraussicht nach noch keine
Vorschlag geben aber dann zeitnah dem
Bundeskanzler ist es wichtig dass das
kabinettparitätisch besetzt ist und
alles weitere erfahren Sie dann im
Zusammenhang mit dem Vorschlägen
ja wir haben gehört paritätische
Besetzung ist dem Kanzler wichtig bleibt
also spannend wäre das wird
Herr Rahm sie haben gerade schon über
diese 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
gesprochen die ja im Jahr 2022 für
Aufsehen erregt haben sie haben aber
auch gesagt dass sie mit der bisherigen
Umsetzung oder mit dem bisherigen
Ausgaben dieses 100 Millionen äh 100
Milliarden Sondervermögens nicht
zufrieden sind wie würde denn ihrer
Meinung nach wie würden den ihrer
Meinung nach die idealen nächsten
Schritte eines Nachfolgers einer
Nachfolgerin aussehen was muss ganz
konkret mit diesen Sondervermögen
geschehen
ich darf noch mal ganz kurz auf die
Aussage von Frau Hoffmann und die
Absicht des Kanzlers zurückkommen
ich habe volles Verständnis dafür wenn
man ein Kabinett paritätisch besetzen
will aber hier geht es mit Blick auf
diese schwierige Aufgabe für mich darum
dass die entsprechende Kompetenz da ist
also entsprechende Gewicht da ist um
möglicherweise auch mit Blick auf die
Zeitachse die Frau von ja gerade bis auf
3 Monate fast ausgedient hat die
entsprechende Schnelligkeit da ist also
sie können im verteilungsministerium
kein indirekt um zulassen wenn es über
einen längeren Zeitraum geht sondern
sowohl das Ministerium als auch die
Truppe als auch die anstehende
Entscheidung brauchen eine schnelle
Lösung und diese Lösung muss Kompetenz
haben muss durch das kräftig sein dies
vielleicht noch mal als Anmerkung zu dem
Thema Parität
die Bundeswehr steht mit Blick auf das
Sondervermögen aber auch mit Blick auf
ihren normalen Haushalt vor einer großen
Herausforderung sie wir wissen dass die
Einsatzbereitschaft der Bundeswehr in
den letzten ich sage mal 10 11 12 Jahren
gewaltig gelitten hat und dass wir als
die können annektiert worden ist durch
Russland 2014 mit Blick auf die
Einsatzbereitschaft der Bundeswehr eine
haarerlebnis gehabt haben wir wissen
auch dass jetzt im vergangenen Jahr als
der keine Krieg begonnen hat dort die
Aggression Russlands begonnen hat sich
beispielsweise der Inspektor des Virus
dazu geäußert hat dass er mit Blick auf
die Thema auf das Thema
Landesverteidigung nicht das leisten
kann was für ihn in diesem Bereich ja
ich sage das mal erforderlich ist wir
haben erlebt jetzt vor wenigen Tagen den
Austausch des Puma durch den Marder mit
Blick auf die very
high-force wo die Bundeswehr in diesem
Jahr mit der Führung aber auch betrunken
Teil entsprechen in der Pflicht steht
das heißt dieses alles zeigt das
Entscheidung für die Bundeswehr
getroffen werden mussten müssen
Stichwort weiterbeschaffung des Pumas
Stichwort weitere Ausrüstung für das
hier die Luftfahrt und die Marine nicht
nur Auflösung wie ich vorhin schon
gesagt habe und das sind Entscheidungen
die im Ministerium jetzt bedeutet werden
müssen und die da auch entsprechend
schnell getroffen werden müssen damit
verbunden ist dann auch im Rahmen der
entsprechenden Haushaltsaufstellung
sowohl für den Verteidigungsetat selber
also den Einzelplan 14 als auch für das
Sondervermögen die Vorbereitung der
entsprechenden Vorlagen die dann im
Parlament über den Haushaltsausschuss
entsprechend bewilligt werden müssen
wenn die Beschaffungsvorhaben ein
Volumen von 25 Millionen Euro
überschreiten die die ersten
Entscheidungen mit Blick auf die
persönliche Ausrüstung der Soldaten sind
gefallen das mittlerweile auch im
Haushalt bereits aufgenommen aber jetzt
geht dieses ganze weiter mit Blick auch
auf Betriebsmittel sprich was habe ich
an Geld für Munition was habe ich an
Geld für Betriebsstoff was habe ich an
Geld für Instandsetzungsarbeiten da gibt
es doch ein grundsätziges Problem
strukturelles Problem im Jahr 2011 ist
entschieden worden dass das für das
Großgerät oder für das Gerät in der
Nutzungsphase das war ja ein also das
Bundesamt für
Infrastruktur Verbesserung für
Beschaffung in insgesamt von von
Material von Informationstechnik und für
die Nutzung dass der entscheidende Punkt
dieses Amt den Koblenz und der
sprechende Abteilungsleiter im BMVg
verantwortlich sind diese Verantwortung
war früher beispielsweise bei den
Inspektoren und diese haben sich da
intensiv darum gekümmert das wäre
vielleicht gut wenn diese Verantwortung
eine spekteure auf der zurückgegeben
wurde das heißt wir haben sowohl
haushaltsmäßige Herausforderungen wir
haben rüstungsmäßige Herausforderung wir
haben auch organisatorische
Herausforderung die angefasst werden
müssen um die Bundeswehr wieder in einen
betriebsfähige Zustand zu bringen
Herr Rams uns erreicht hier gerade noch
die Meldung wer Lambrecht im Ministerium
nachfolgen wird soll erst am Dienstag
verkündet werden das hat zumindest die
FAZ aus Regierungskreisen erfahren aus
Respekt vor ihrer Entscheidung an diesem
Montag werde mit der Verkündigung der
mit der Verkündung der Nachfolgeregelung
bis morgen gewartet heißt es
vielleicht abschließend noch mal ein
Kommentar aus der Community von ähm sie
oder er schreibt auf Youtube das
Verteidigungsministerium ist immer ein
schleudersitzministerium fast alle
bisherigen Vorgänger hatten nur relativ
kurze Amtszeit bis auf die Frau von der
Leyen die hat sich tapfer geschlagen und
darin abschließend noch mal meine letzte
Frage sie haben gesagt das Thema
Landesverteidigung ist ein großes Thema
bei der Bundeswehr wo es Aufholbedarf
gibt ich frage mich jetzt ist das
wirklich die alleinige Schuld von Frau
Lamprecht die jetzt ein Jahr im Amt war
oder ist das was für bisherige Vorgänger
Vorgängerin schon
angezettelt haben weil Thema
Landesverteidigung einfach jetzt ganz
lange nicht mehr wirklich so stark auf
der Agenda war
ich darf jetzt ein bisschen weiter
ausführen holen und erstmal ihren Nutzer
widersprechen der verteilungsminister
rühr war sechs Jahre im Handel das ist
schon deutlich länger also Frau von der
Leyen gewesen ist und daher wir haben
auch vorher schon Minister gehabt die
längere Zeiten verteilungsministerium
bestanden haben und etliche von den
Ministern sind hinterher aus politischen
Gründen Schmidt beispielsweise weil er
dann in der Hierarchie des Kabinetts
aufgerückt ist aus dem
verteilungsministerium gegangen das
heißt nicht alle die Minister waren sind
über dieses Ministerium gefallen so wir
haben Minister gehabt die dieses Amt
auch entsprechend gut ausgeübt haben und
in einer vernünftigen Art und Weise
wahrgenommen haben zu dem zweiten Teil
Ihrer Frage
ja es ist ein bisschen schwierig sage
ich mal ganz vorsichtig
dieses Ministerium zu führen der eine
Tag der jetzt möglicherweise verloren
geht für die Entscheidung wenn die
Entscheidung erst morgen fällt das ist
in meinen Augen in Ordnung aber wichtig
ist dass dann praktisch der Minister
auch die Ministerin entsprechend auch
mit hoher Geschwindigkeit in die Aufgabe
reinsetzen die Aufgaben aufnehmen kann
das heißt ein gewisses Vorwissen sollte
schon vor allem sein und der Staat
sollte nicht bei Null erfolgen da habe
ich sie doch mal mitten in den letzten
Teil Ihrer Frage zu wiederholen
ja ich scrolle hier noch mal hoch
meine Frage ach so das war jetzt der
youtube-kommentar meine Frage war
ob das jetzt wirklich die alleinige
Schuld ist von Frau Lambrecht zu sagen
dass das Thema Landesverteidigung nicht
mehr so stark im Fokus war
eindeutig nein da Frau Lambrecht im
Prinzip wenn Sie so wollen überhaupt
keine Aktien drin sondern die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat im Jahre
2011 entschieden trotz eines anders
laufenden damals neuen strategischen
Konzept der NATO dass man sich
ausschließlich auf die Auslandseinsätze
konzentrieren wollte weil man ja der
Meinung war dass europäische Umfeld sei
zu 100% friedlich es ging im
Auslandseinsätze stabilisierungseinsätze
das war eine Erleichterung für die
damalige Regierung einfach aus dem
Grunde weil eine Armee einsatzbereit für
Auslandseinsätze eröffnet einem die
Möglichkeiten Material für die
Vorbereitung der Auslandseinsätze zu
verschieben
man braucht keine Vollausstattung nicht
alles Material muss einsatzbereit sein
und da ist halt eben der Weckruf im
Jahre 2014 bereits erfolgt also 2011 wir
haben heute fast 12 Jahre oder helfen
Halbjahres 2014 kam der Weckruf mit
Blick auf die Annektierung der Krim und
mit Blick auf den Krieg im Don Bass
spätestens da hätte man wach werden
können das ist auch damals erfolgt man
hat von Trendwenden gesprochen bei
Personal bei Material bei Ausrüstung und
bei vielen Dingen mehr nur diese
Trendwenden konnten in dieser Form nicht
umgesetzt werden weil der
Verteidigungshaushalt das nicht
hergegeben wird das heißt wir stehen in
vielen Bereichen in dieser Frage im
Prinzip noch an der Stelle wo wir
2014/15 oder 15 16 gestanden haben und
hier gibt es Nachholbedarf die
Verantwortung dafür trifft in keinem
fallen
Herr Rams danke dass Sie bei uns waren
und die Fragen unserer Community
beantwortet beantwortet haben ich denke
sie bleiben da dran wir bleiben daran
beim ZDF vielen Dank
ich danke auch wünsche noch einen
schönen Tag
ja danke auch an euch für eure
zahlreichen Fragen und Kommentare zum
Thema vielleicht gucken wir zum Schluss
noch mal kurz auf die Stimmung in der
Community meet hat 919 sagt auf Youtube
das traurige bei Lamprecht war ja bei
Frau Lamprecht war ja dass sie keine
Anstalten gemacht hat sich wirklich in
das Thema einzuarbeiten sie stehen sehr
sehr lustlos zu sein und vielleicht zum
Schluss noch mal einen Kommentar zur
Parität im Kabinett da sagt auch
Facebook Kurt Jürgen Janot ein Mann ist
nicht durch sein geschlech dazu
prädestiniert Verteidigungsminister zu
werden das kann eine Frau genauso gut
das andere Verteidigungsminister ist
gerade in Kriegszeiten extrem schwierig
auch und gerade vor dem Hintergrund das
Jahrzehnte lang die Bundeswehr kaputt
gespart wurde ja wie sich das Ganze
weiterentwickelt wir bleiben auf jeden
Fall für euch dran danke für eure Fragen
und bis zum nächsten Mal wenn ihr mögt